I loved working here at Morningstar to
me it's unlike the government you know
we have a lot of freedom here I love
this job I plan on working here until I
retire because it's so different
self-management is at a very very high
level exactly the way you live when you
go home from work we just actually keep
that hat on when you come to work at
Morningstar
[Music]
the Morningstar was founded in 1970 by
Chris roofer he was at the time a
college student UCLA and he leased his
first truck a big rig and started
hauling Tomatoes into and out of
factories and over a few years of doing
that he kind of had some thoughts about
how factories could be run and in 1990
he started what was the morning start
packing companies very first facility in
Los Banos California we've grown since
1990 to three very large facilities
those facilities process about 40
percent of California's process tomato
crop we are the largest process of
tomatoes in the world so who's the boss
I think in a traditional organization
there's kind of a very rigid
interpretation of who the boss is
we have no bosses here at Morningstar I
have no boss so well
everybody is up basically above when you
come in on board at Morningstar you and
the colleagues around you are expected
to kind of take a timeout to sit down
examine yourself your your competencies
your your what you have to bring to the
table the things you're trying to
achieve in your career and in your life
and organize your work accordingly and
as long as you are achieving your
mission and the enterprise is achieving
their mission there really aren't a
whole lot of boundaries around how that
works and you really what you're doing
is you're working with other business
units you know I may want to get
something done the operations side so
what I have to do is not because I'm the
so-called head of quality or whatever
your job title would supposedly be you
need to go and you need to negotiate
with another business unit
maybe it's the evaporation guys and we
need to negotiate but at the end of the
day it's what's best for the company but
we don't have a structured structured
hiring process here at Morningstar as a
group as a family were involved and we
make those decisions together you hire
the right people you get the right
person in the job you don't need to
micro
there is no micromanaging here and and
it's it's really a breath of fresh air
to be honest with you
politics as a kind of concept is
probably the are the absence thereof
with the morning stars probably the most
interesting thing that most people
notice almost immediately you know
there's no kind of trying to climb the
ladder or vying for resources that are
kind of scarce and being doled out by
somebody all of us are free to you know
buy what we need to buy to do our job
right it's not that there is unlimited
funds it's simply that you have the
ability to expend the resources you need
as long as you get the appropriate you
know get people involved who have
expertise and are gonna be affected by
it you have the ability to spend money
and if I need to spend $80,000 on a lab
instrument i buy the lab instrument in
my other company that doesn't fly not
only would I not get it the the process
to get to that point is it's very
difficult the things that quash people
are overwhelming bureaucracy and red
tape and ability to do the things that
you know beyond a shadow of a doubt are
the things that need to be done I think
the people on the floor are probably the
best ones to make the decisions you know
we see it run we've done the maintenance
on it we know more about it than anybody
our fundamental to our way of doing
things is that the person with the most
insight the most knowledge should be the
person making the decision period end of
story
knowledge is what gets you respect here
not a job title we've pushed the
fundamentals management out to everyone
in the enterprise
we've also pushed the fundamentals of
creativity and innovation out to
everyone the enterprise very explicit
about the fact that that the most
important thing with an organization is
improvement the best thing for me
working here at Morningstar is I'm
constantly learning constantly growing
constantly being exposed to things I
wouldn't be exposed to I think I've
improved our dice area a lot the last
three years I started with other
colleagues helped with full document
control program we added a a product
hopper to one of our our lines so we
increase the speed line speed from 80
cans a minute to about 150 cans of
minutes I think most human beings have
some internal drive that they want to do
good things that create some sort of
benefit for people it's very good to
feel like you're bringing in
to accompany historically the most
prosperous happiest human societies on a
very macro scale are those societies
that are built on the same fundamental
principles and so our thought is that if
that works with a whole lot of people
can it work with not quite as many
people within the confines of you know a
company everybody takes a lot of pride
in what they do here I think the
self-management kind of breeds that it
it breeds accountability
I feel like Morningstar's mine ate the I
believe all of us here take ownership
and that's one of things that makes it
great when work follows you home but in
a good way when it helps you feel good
about what you're doing he'd that kind
of growth rubs off in a personal life
the what Morningstar has kind of become
as a place where people learn what it
means to have true individual freedom
and personally be responsible for their
actions and that's actually very
invigorating thing for most people and
so over time they start to kind of embed
this into their personality into their
fundamental character and they kind of
carry that away when they leave
Morningstar which is a very kind of
interesting phenomenon I've grown much
more here at Morningstar than I think I
could ever have grown and my other jobs
I'm very proud to work here very proud
[Music]